ils n'ont que 13 ou 14 ans mais autour
de cette table ce sont des élus
départementaux 60 collégiens de
cinquième et quatrième élus au conseil
départemental jeunes et citoyens
et s'ils sont là c'est avant tout pour
faire avancer des projets qui les
concernent
on doit faire des séances de théâtre et
du basket ball et aussi parce qu'on fait
dans nos collèges en fait de la sieste
bah du coup on a besoin des lignes sinon
les collèges d'avoir en plus de ce truc
essayer d'avoir plus de trucs je suis
pas pouvoir faire plus de sport au
collège pas encore de la politique mais
déjà un engagement penser qu'ils peuvent
agir concrètement et apporter un
complément par rapport aux élus adultes
il ya beaucoup toujours que que ce que
certains veulent faire dans le collège
et que pour fait pas du coup je me suis
dit que peut-être que si on se présente
et bah ça pouvait nous faire réaliser ce
que tu voulais faire c'est toujours un
regard qui est petit c'est à dire que
les indices voient pas forcément des
trucs que l'on voit et inversement
donc c'est vraiment un échange un rôle
qui familiarisent ces jeunes avec des
institutions qui paraissent parfois
lointaines utile aussi pour faire naître
des envies de s'investir
alors qu'il est de plus en plus
difficile de trouver des élus surtout au
niveau local que la conviction que parmi
ces jeunes qui sont réunis ce matin dans
10 ans 15 ans ou 20 ans on aura
peut-être parmi eux des des élus dans
des conseils municipaux dans des causes
dans le conseil départemental jeunes et
j'ai la conviction c'est une très bonne
école
c'est vraiment un exercice citoyen et
c'est une belle responsabilité
démocratique de s'être engagé à le faire
les conseillers jeunes sont élus pour
deux ans ils disposeront d'un budget de
46000 euros pour couvrir leurs besoins
et les réalisations au cours de leur
mandat